hi guys it's me again Guillermo UI
design involves aligning and lining up
control nodes precisely matching margins
and proportions on top of the anchor and
layout system the dos 2d workspace comes
with the grid guides and smart snapping
tools to help you place and align your
UI components faster in this video you
learn how to use the grid and the grid
snapping options guides which are
virtual lines to help you align sprites
together as well as a smart snapping
options to use the snapping options we
first have to activate it snapping to do
so we have to click on this blue magnet
on the toolbar or press s to toggle it
on and off
by the foe any GDR control node will
snap to the grid to make it visible we
have to press G or go to view and click
on show grid keep in mind that is
happening will also work even if the
grid is hidden
the grid allows us to move our nodes on
a grid like environment if I have
already used tile maps in or outside of
Godot it's pretty similar
although amazing basic most UI designers
use grid snapping to place and move
sprites around quickly and precisely
by default the DOS grid is configured to
be 10 pixels by 10 pixels we can change
that by clicking on these three dots
next to our magnet and clicking on
configure is nap
this menu allows us to configure
snapping for both the grid and the
rotation steps a lot of the sprites that
you find online use powers of 2 as their
sizes so it's really common to use
similar values for your grid in general
you want to set it based on your games
the sprite size for instance here we are
using a grid of 64 pixels by 64 pixels
you should use this grid as a base unit
to set the size and position of your UI
elements and fix it steps this is going
to save you time for instance the 4 bars
that we have on top of our UI if you
look at the bottom ones you notice that
they are offset it exactly by half the
length of the top ones this was easily
done using grid snap each time we are
moving one of these bars on the x-axis
we're actually moving it one part of its
complete length if we go back to the
configure tab menu you notice that we
also have an offset setting this setting
will add an offset on the x and y if
needed the grid starts off at the origin
of your game meaning at the position 0
on X and 0 on Y in case you don't want
it to start here you can change this by
using the offset
the grid will also work on 2d notes and
it's usually a really good idea to
always keep it on when placing and
moving nodes as it's going to help us
keep them aligned correctly
of the grid Godot 3 also provides us
with guides and smite snapping tools
guides are infinite horizontal and
vertical lines you can place anywhere
and use as a visual reference or to snap
nose to to see guides in the viewport go
to view show guides or press Y on your
keyboard to toggle invisible make sure
that you also have rulers and on as well
as your drag guides from them to target
an on and off press R or go to view and
click on show rulers to create a new
guide click and drag from the horizontal
and vertical ruler if you click and drag
from the top left corner you create a
both horizontal and vertical guide at
the same time
notice that guides also use snapping
options they are going to align to your
notes bounding boxes and also move on
the grid if it's active to move a guide
click and drag from the ruler is
starting on a purple line and to delete
a guide just drag it back to the ruler
- snap - the guide you need to turn on
is nap - guide on the smart snap in menu
this was used on our GUI scene you can
notice that the buttons at the bottom
are offset from the grid on the y-axis
I use the guide as a margin where I
wanted to align the top edges of my UI
components
on the map seen on the other hand I'm
using his nap to other nodes to keep the
obstacles against one another this was
only possible because the obstacle scene
has a sprite which is offset it from its
route the reason behind using is napped
others instead of using the grid is
because the grid was too big for our is
my obstacles to be snapped to it
correctly
we could have also decreased the size of
the grid instead of using this might
snap setting which brings us to the
point set at the beginning of the video
the grid is one of the most powerful and
versatile tools you have at your
disposal
and another is mark is napping setting
that we have is the is nap to parent
this setting is going to is nap here are
nodes origin to its parent bounding box
now let's look at a last few basic yet
essential is napping options the pixel
is nap is used to force your nose to
snap to the pixel grid this is important
for pixel art games because placing them
between pixels is going to lead some
visual art affects the relative snap is
useful when we have an O that's offset
from the main grid but we still want it
to move on the grid steps for instance
our player here is not on the main grid
if I press G you can see that it's
offset but if I select it because we
have relative snap selected it's still
moving on a grid like manner but it has
it the origin of the grid set should be
at its origin and lastly we have the
rotation snap which can be configured on
the configure snap setting and it's used
to rotate our node in fixed set
increments as you can see the player is
being rotated on 15 degrees increments
and to finish it off here are two tips
to use when you are using is marked
snapping and snapping in general
the Neptuno tanker is only going to work
on control notes because they are the
only types of notes that actually have
an anchor and because of the grid being
really dense sometimes when you're using
grid snapping it will generally take
precedence over other it snapping
options is going to give you the feeling
that the other snappings
aren't really working but they actually
are but it's just because your grid is
too dense so it's usually a good idea to
turn the grid off or the grid snapping
off when you're trying to use other is
mark snapping options
thank you so much for watching this
video as usual you can find this project
on the github repository which is going
to be linked in the video description so
if you want to play around with it feel
free if you have any feedback it's
really appreciated and I'll see you in
the next time
you